نزحت يوم 710 اول ايام الحرب الساعه 11
الظهر لاني كنت معي طلق والام الولاده بدي
على وجه ولادي يعني هو انه في
تووم ولدت لحالي بالمستشفى ولدت وطلعت
ظهري من المستشفى طلعوني لانه فيش في
حالات ثانيه حكي بدها تج تولد مكانك انا
مش قادره اقف على رجلي والد يعني توائم
ولدتهم صعبه جدا اجيت
هنا انا مش بس عندي الثوم عندي كمان اطفال
اثنين
ثانيين انا قاعده في مكان في ممر ثلاث
عائلات معي يعني احنا ه يمكن حلكه 25 نفر
بنام اطفال
ونساء هنا احنا من يوم ما جينا ماكناش
البروتين كل اكلنا معلبات ومواد حافظه
تسمح ل ارضع
اثنين الوكاله بتعطينا شويه معلبات نضطر
نبيعهم ونشتري علبه الحليب
للاولاد يا نتغدى يا نتعشى زيك حياتنا في
مدارس
اللواء ما اخذوا حقهم النهائي لا في
تطعيمات ولا في اي شي لازمه بخاف عليهم من
كل حاجه من الامراض من البرد
والسقعه من الصواريخ مش بتتخيلي حالي يعني
انا حعيش كمان شوي اليوم اللي بعيش بنحمد
الله
[موسيقى]
عليه انا اولادي بلش يمرضوا من اول شهر في
الكهربا ما بتجينا ف اولادي في الليل قحقح
كثير بخنق لبلغم بيطلع سدرهم بينخان انا
ما بشوفهم بالليل
منيح على هالحال مش قادره احميهم لا بره
ولا
جوا احنا هنا في منطقه المواصي بقولوا
عنها فقرين اليهود عننا ع ابراج حامد
موجودين اليهود موجودين بري فبير موا
علينا في الصف مش بعيد عنا متر ونص مترين
فصرت ايش اساوي الف الاولاد هيك بالملفات
واسكر عشان ما يشمو ريحه ال بس على الفاضي
دخلت الريحه بزياده اقولوا لا سكر سكر هي
العابب فرش اه اه هي الوردات اللي نن
جبناها من المصنع عروسه كنت مجهزه غرفه
نوم وسرر وكسوه كامله البيبي فتخيل ان
نسبت وراي ذكريات حلوه وتجهيزات واواوي
والعاب واغراضي انا حتى الان ثلاث شهور
حرب حاسه حالي في صدمه مش متخيله الوضع
اللي صار نص قرايبي ماتوا استشهدوا بيتي
راح بلدي كلها اليهود اخذتها ذاكر يا عززي
لما بابا كان يطلع على الشغل صوركم شارع
[موسيقى]
البياره انا بعد الحرب وين بح بحال بيتي
راح قرايبي لو راح عنده لهم بيوت كل
بيوتنا راح روح
بحالنا هي بزعلك في
الموضوع